le déverrouillage de confinement se
précise en europe continent durement
touchée par le coronavirus avec plus de
122 mille décès au niveau mondial la
barre macabre des deux cent mille morts
à elle été franchi hier une situation
tragique pour l' oms qui émet des doutes
sur l'immunité des personnes déjà
contaminées
retour sur la situation en europe avec
clément hospital ses rues vidée de ses
habitants ces populations retranchés
chez elle voilà maintenant six semaines
que l'europe vit au ralenti
le vieux continent s'apprête à amorcer
son déconfinement amputé de plus de 120
milles de ses citoyens au royaume uni
boris johnson prépare son grand retour
après son infection covit 19 début avril
le pays de nous dépasser le seuil des 20
mille décès dans ces hôpitaux
le fait de passer la barre des 20000
décès nous rappelle à tous comme je les
dis en commençant cette présentation
qu'il est absolument essentiel
absolument essentiel que nous continuons
à suivre les directives de distanciation
sociale parce que nous voyons les
bénéfices que nous en retirons et nous
continuerons à constater ses bénéfices
nous ne continuerons a constaté la
réduction des décès que si nous
continuons tous allaient suivre
plus au sud en europe l'espagne autorise
des exercices physiques et les
promenades à partir de ce week end
jusqu'à leur soumis un confinement total
les mineurs de moins de 14 ans pourront
sortir une heure par jour des nouvelles
mesures de déconfinement s'appliqueront
à partir du 2 mai si l'épidémie de
coronavirus continue à reculer
désescalade sera progressive qu'est-ce
que cela signifie
cela ne signifie pas que nous allons
retrouver soudainement toutes nos
activités et notre mobilité sociale mais
que cela se fera par étapes pour chaque
domaine d'activité les étapes
successives seront fixés un lent retour
à la vie d'avant qui n'est pas au goût
de tout le monde à berlin la police
anti-émeute allemande a arrêté une
dizaine de manifestants mobilisés contre
les mesures de confinement
la baisse du nombre de coups
nomination a permis la réouverture de
petits commerces mais les règles de
distanciation sont maintenus jusqu'au 3
mai outre-rhin en italie une campagne
nationale de tests sérologiques
commencera début mai sur cent cinquante
mille personnes pour vérifier la
présence d'anticorps chez la population
la plus meurtrie d'europe